the Lord of the Rings is a big deal JRR
Tolkien's epic fantasy created a genre
inspired a series of hit movies and
single-handedly altered the economy of
New Zealand so you can imagine the
excitement when HarperCollins announced
that Tolkien's spin-off story about
lovers Beren and lúthien is to be
published as a standalone novel in 2017
exactly a century after Tolkien's
started writing it here's everything you
need to know about the new Lord of the
Rings spin-off sunrise JRR Tolkien wrote
numerous stories about the history of
middle-earth some of them incomplete or
contradictory after his death
Tolkien's son Christopher added a few of
them into loose collections like
unfinished tales and The Silmarillion
Beren and lúthien is Christopher's
second attempt at editing some of his
father's middle-earth backstory into a
standalone novel the first was the
children of húrin a relentlessly
miserable tale about a family doomed by
a terrible curse fortunately Beren and
lúthien is a lot more upbeat though
exactly what will be in the book is a
bit of a mystery
Tolkien produced multiple versions of
the basic story including a draft in
which Sauron appears as a needle cat and
an unfinished poem that suddenly cuts
off mid werewolf attack lore of the
Rings
although Beren and lúthien takes place
in the same world as the Hobbit and Lord
of the Rings it's set over 6,500 years
earlier to put that into perspective the
land where the story takes place sinks
beneath the ocean in a massive cataclysm
about four millennia before hobbits even
appear as a species the world isn't even
the same shape since a particularly
angry God violently changes it from flat
to round between the two stories in
other words you probably shouldn't
expect your favorite characters to pop
in for a cameo that said return of saw
on the only character to appear in both
Lord of the Rings and Beren and lúthien
is Sauron who has the excuse of being
immortal interestingly Sauron is
essentially a second tier villain in
Beren and lúthien the real threat in the
story is saurons boss a guy named
Morgoth the original Dark Lord in
Tolkien's mythology
he's a being so powerful that a massive
army of angels eventually has to invade
middle-earth to remove him from the
picture even Sauron is terrified of him
and with good reason as the ultimate
source of evil Morgoth was behind the
creation of dragons
orcs werewolves and trolls he
even boasts a personal bodyguard of
balrog x' each as powerful as the one
that killed Gandalf that one time
personal story
Tolkien's wife Edith was the inspiration
for the beautiful lúthien whose songs
enchant Morgoth and move even the
personification of death to tears Edith
meant Tolkien when he was just 16 his
guardian forbade him to see her but
within hours of turning 21 he proposed
and she accepted Tolkien later wrote to
his son Christopher that the love story
was first conceived in a small woodland
glade filled with hemlocks at Roos in
Yorkshire in those days Edith's hair was
raven her skin clear her eyes brighter
than you have seen them and she could
sing and dance the two were eventually
buried together sharing a simple
tombstone that bore the names Beren and
lúthien
badass heroine one of the common
criticisms of Lord of the Rings and The
Hobbit is that nearly all of the heroes
are men the book version of The Hobbit
famously doesn't have a single female
character a owen basically stands alone
in Lord of the Rings books although
Peter Jackson expanded our Irwin's role
for the movies while he invented toriel
out of thin air Beren and lúthien seems
like it's heading in the same direction
when Lu thien's father gives Baron a
quest to win his daughter's hand in
marriage in a subversion Baron and his
all-male band of companions fail
catastrophic Lee lúthien has to escape
from her father and personally faced
down Sauron to rescue her warrior and
distress from his dungeon for the rest
of the story she does all the heavy
lifting successfully stealing a
priceless jewel from Morgoth while Baron
tags along effectively lúthien takes
matters into her own hands and completes
the quest herself to ensure she could
marry the man she loves Eagles to the
rescue at a key point in the story it
seems certain that Beren and lúthien are
about to be captured and then three huge
Eagles swooped in out of nowhere and
carry them to safety if that sounds
familiar it's because Tolkien used the
same plot device to save Bilbo and the
dorbz in The Hobbit and then he used it
again to save Sam and Frodo at the end
of Lord of the Rings
thanks to Baron lúthien we know the
Eagles have been pulling this stunt for
at least 7,000 years you'd think Sauron
would forget invading Gondor for a while
and focus on killing these Eagles since
they're clearly evils most persistent
enemy in Tolkien's continuity
cool new monsters if you're bored with
orcs and dragons have no fear Beren and
lúthien introduces some exciting new
creatures to the world of middle-earth
including vampires and werewolves I was
thinking maybe I should just bring a
broom down here for you if you wanted to
sweep up some of these skeletons
unfortunately the versions of the story
that have been published so far don't
give us much detail on what these
creatures actually look like so no word
yet on whether or not middle-earth
vampires Sparkle the original Aragorn
and Arwen one aspect of the spin-off
that should be familiar to fans is the
central love story just like Aragorn and
our Owen Beren and lúthien are immortal
man and an immortal elf princess
[Music]
like Arwen lúthien suspects the
relationship will cause her great sorrow
but she loves Baron and can't bring
herself to abandon him and just like
Elrond Luo Tian's father Fingal is
deeply opposed to the relationship in
fact Aragorn is very aware of the
parallels and repeatedly compares our
Owen to lúthien so many you say Desmond
a of North you okay in fact Elrond and
Aaron are Beren and lúthien descendants
that's why Arwen is able to choose to
become mortal at the end of Return of
the King and remain with Aragorn lúthien
sad song moved the God like the lard to
let her become mortal so she and Baron
could be together even in death the
Valar then allowed their half elf half
human descendants to choose whether or
not to be mortal like humans or immortal
like elves while Elrond chose to become
an elf
his daughter made the choice of lúthien
become immortal to stay with her one
true love
five
[Music]
kind of makes her singing Valentine's
Day cards seem pretty crappy by
comparison huh click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to